The Nightmare Before Christmas is a
beloved classic one of the most
singularly quirky and amazing animated
films holiday movies and musicals of all
time all rolled into one coming from the
mind of producer Tim Burton and bearing
his distinct visual stamp the
stop-motion animated feature has become
a staple of the holidays since its 1993
release one of the true joys of The
Nightmare Before Christmas is how
amazingly true it is to the tone and
spirit of both Halloween and Christmas
and it's easy to see why the film has
become a yearly tradition for so many
but considering its financial and
critical success and its impact on the
world of pop culture what's not so easy
to puzzle out is why we never got a
sequel to the classic film why did we
never get the Nightmare Before Christmas
- it's not like the idea hasn't been
kicked around in particular the film's
director Henry Selick who would go on to
work on two additional stop-motion
features 2006's James and the Giant
Peach and 2009's Coraline has gone on
record stating that he could be enticed
to return to Halloweentown but the
notion was complicated by Disney it
seems that the house of mouse was only
interested in a sequel to the classic on
one specific condition one that Selleck
wasn't too keen on in a 2009 interview
Selleck revealed that discussions about
a sequel had in fact taken place saying
a few years back Disney spoke to me and
the sad thing was at the time they said
if we do a sequel it will have to be CG
I was really disappointed I asked why
and they didn't think stop-motion was a
viable way to make movies I don't think
Tim would allow a CG sequel there's been
a few stories proposed and a few
discussions but that's a Ridley Tim's
decision in sharing this Selleck hit
upon one major roadblock to any sequel
to The Nightmare Before Christmas Burton
who first conceived the story and
characters in a poem he wrote as a young
man in the early 80s in a 2006 interview
with MTV News the filmmaker indicated
that he may not be terribly open to the
idea of any sequel CG or otherwise he
told MTV I was always very protective of
the movie not to do sequels or things of
that kind
you know Jack visits Thanksgiving world
other kinds of things just because I
felt the movie had a purity to it and
the people that like it because it's not
a mass-market kind of thing it was
important to kind of keep that purity of
it that's certainly understandable but
even if some persistent executive had
been able to convince Burton to make the
Nightmare Before Christmas - anyway he
wanted
there were many years during which it
just wouldn't have been possible because
the filmmaker wasn't speaking to his
star Danny Elfman who provided Jack
singing voice in case you're not
familiar with Elfman you should know
that you are in fact familiar with
Elfman the former frontman for New Wave
pioneers Oingo Boingo Elfman has
composed so much music for film and
television
including the iconic Simpsons theme that
it had be virtually impossible to have
never heard any of his work
Elfman has worked with Burton on no
fewer than 16 films and during the
course of their long professional
relationship the two famously eccentric
personalities didn't always play nice
together in a 2015 interview elfin
revealed that the pair had a big blowup
right after work on the Nightmare Before
Christmas was completed one which would
have kept the musical voice of Jack from
participating in any sequel for some
time
Elfman recalled it was in the middle of
a very intense period and I think things
came to a boil it's inevitable that in
over a quarter of a century two
personalities like us and I can't
pretend that I'm not volatile and was
more so then there's got to be some kind
of explosion the pair resolved their
differences several years later but they
did lose a lot of time during which the
Nightmare Before Christmas was fresh in
the minds of the movie-going public to
be sure the original film would be a
tough act to follow even assuming that
Burton Elfman and silic could be coaxed
back on board you may have heard however
that the house of mouse has recently
been diving into its archives in pursuit
of box-office gold meaning that if we
ever do get more Nightmare Before
Christmas it may not necessarily be in
the form of a sequel Disney's recent
live-action remakes of its classic
animated properties have for the most
part done bonkers box-office interesting
wait the sole exception is 20 19's Dumbo
a comparative flop that just happened to
have been directed by Tim Burton not
that this would keep Disney from eyeing
The Nightmare Before Christmas for the
live-action treatment in fact it's
recently been rumored that the studio is
considering doing just
and these rumors surfaced early in 2019
before Aladdin and the Lion King each
scored over a billion dollars at the
worldwide box office with move on The
Little Mermaid and more looking to
continue the trend it stands to reason
that the mouse house might be taking a
hard look at their stop-motion Holiday
Classic for possible live-action
adaptation of course it should be
stressed that these are merely rumors
and are in no way confirmed but at this
point a live-action redo seems a lot
more likely than a stop-motion sequel
honestly we'll take either one just for
the chance to see Jack the pumpkin King
back up on the big screen one more time
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite films are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]